do you think the mainstream media are
biased yes
that's why you watch trigonometry but we
all still read the news and the thing
you really want to be doing is comparing
how different publications cover the
same story
that's where ground news come in drawing
from 40 000
media outlets around the world and over
30
000 new stories per day they empower you
to arrive at the truth yourself don't do
that just watch trigonometry everyone
here at trigonometry
loves ground news because they've got so
many brilliant features
but there's one feature in particular
that we all find incredibly useful
it's the blind spot feature it is the
news blind spot and what this allows you
to see
is what your particular media that
you're consuming whether you're right or
left
is not covering there are certain issues
that the right wing media
will never cover and therefore if you
only watch the right wing you won't know
equally on the left it's the same thing
and what the news blind spot
allows you to do is to get the
information that the people who you're
getting your media from
are not telling you and they've also got
an amazing website which is ground
dot news for those of us who live in the
21st century
unlike france's and have phones just
download the app from wherever you get
your homes
when people were being killed
over cartoons the reaction
should have been immediate printing of
those cartoons
on every single western media possible
as a show of strength to say no we
believe in freedom of expression we
believe in freedom of speech
we will not be bullied we will not
capitulate
hello and welcome to trigonometry
i'm francis foster i'm constantine
kitchen and this is a show for you
if you want honest conversations with
fascinating people
our brilliant guest today is an author
and humans rights activist
yazma mohammed welcome to trigonometry
thank you so much for having me it's a
pleasure to be here
it's great to have you here listen
obviously the the reason we wanted to
talk to you is you've been pretty
outspoken recently
in the wake of a number of terrorist
attacks in france and there's a broader
issue to discuss as well
uh i can't wait to get to that because
it's a really important conversation but
maybe it's best for for us to start off
by uh
you telling our viewers a little bit
about who you are and what is your
backstory how have you come to the place
that you're in because it is very very
interesting
to put it mildly yeah so i
um i grew up in canada to a
muslim family who were very religious
and
so i went to islamic school
i was put in hijab at the age of nine so
that's what covers everything but your
face and hands
and um you know your your typical
islamic religious thing so you'd have to
wake up before
the sun rises to pray and then you pray
five times a day and the last one being
before you go
before the sun or after the sun sets um
so being in the north because i grew up
in canada
that ended up causing a lot of problems
with the very long days
sometimes and so there's a lot of sleep
deprivation that's my memory of
childhood
and like in ramadan as well so ramadan
you can't
you can't eat from sunrise to sunset so
that meant that you know some days it
would be
like 10 or 11 hours of not eating
when you're a kid is is pretty tough so
it was it was a pretty
strict muslim upbringing um
that i didn't realize was really strict
i thought it was just the way it was
because everybody that we knew was like
that too
and um i guess i was a bit problematic
because i was always asking questions i
didn't
you know i would just ask basic
questions all the time things didn't
make sense to me
you know how were all the prophets
muslim
if muhammad is the one who started islam
how were adam and eve muslim too that
doesn't make any sense
just the most basic questions like that
that i that i'd ask
i get in trouble because that means it's
the devil whispering in your ear
um you know not having faith or
questioning your faith meant that you're
a bad person
so my mom decided
that she needed to marry me off to
somebody
who was strong enough to control me
and so they chose a member of al-qaeda
and i say they meaning my mom was
married
to a man so her and my dad broke up
when i was very young i didn't grow up
with my dad
but she remarried a man who was already
married and already had three kids
because an islam a man can have up to
four wives
and so she was his second concurrent
wife
and together they forced me into a
marriage
with a member of al-qaeda who was 15
years older than me
and um i had a daughter with him
pretty soon and
i wanted to get away from him obviously
because he was abusive and you know
just a horrible human being but it
wasn't until i had my daughter that i
found the courage to do that
because i wanted to protect her from
having the life that
i grew up in i wanted her to have a
different life and her to have freedom
and her to have choices and
so through a long series of events um
that i outline in my book unveiled
strategically just very stylish straight
out there
excellent very slick um
through it you know it wasn't easy
obviously it was very difficult and it
was
uh just through the skin of my teeth i
was able to get away
and go to university which i never
imagined i'd be able to do
and when i was in university i just took
a
history of religions course because it
was going to be focused on the three
monotheistic religions and i thought
well you know i know for sure i'll ace a
third of this course because i went to
islamic schools and my mom was the head
like the head of the islamic studies
department and we had to make sure that
we always did well otherwise would make
her look bad
and so i knew the religion inside out
and so i thought well this will be you
know an easy a or whatever
and i never imagined that it was going
to change my life entirely
and uh everything unraveled once i
started to take that
learn about my religion sort of from
a with a critical eye we looked at it
you know from an objective point of view
and i was allowed to ask questions and
it was a safe space like the my
professor was
um he grew up in lebanon he grew up
christian in lebanon
and so he kind of understood a lot of my
background and stuff and he wasn't the
kind of prof that would be
concerned about islamophobia or bigotry
or whatever like we could
actually have conversations in the
classroom
um and so yeah it all unraveled from
there
and uh 911 happened and that also really
helped to push me out
and uh and that's that and then i
you know i went on living my life got
remarried had another daughter
you know and i stayed quiet about
everything just from fear mostly
i knew assam was in prison but i also
knew he was
connected to al-qaeda so he'd have
friends everywhere
so i changed my daughter's name changed
my name
we moved cities quite often um
and eventually i was able to relax
and kind of forget that that was my
background like just go on with my life
just buried it basically
never really dealt with it and then
the infamous episode of bill maher with
sam harris and ben affleck happened
and in that episode sam harris
and bill maher were trying to talk about
the problems with islam and how
the issues in that religion were so
anti-liberal anti-women
you know anti-freedom etc and ben
affleck
just refused to let them have that
conversation
he jumped in and called them gross and
racist and etc
so the next day my facebook was covered
with friends
who were you know so
proud of ben affleck for shutting down
that gross racist
man and done it and i'm like oh my gosh
like i have
i have failed you people i have not
because i kept it all to myself i didn't
say anything
and while i was watching that episode i
almost i teared up
i was so excited and happy
that these two american men
on national television were talking
about me
essentially because they were talking
about people who left islam and they
gave the statistic
of like close to 90 of people in egypt
feel that people who leave islam should
be executed well that's me
my family is from egypt and i left islam
they actually care about me
on real time with bill maher like it
just felt like
i was finally being seen and heard for
the first time
something that i was even too scared to
talk about with my friends
i was seeing on television
and ben affleck came swooping in like
the white knight that he is and he
shut down the conversation and the
reason
you know i felt really betrayed
obviously by by ben affleck especially
since he did a movie called dogma where
he had no
problem criticizing christianity for the
same issues
but when it came to islam suddenly we
can't talk about those things we can't
talk about
you know the much more atrocious things
that are happening
in this day and age because of the fact
that there are so many islamic
theocracies
and so that is what inspired me to start
writing my book
and once i started writing my book
i just organically ended up in activism
it wasn't something that i ever chose
it just kind of happened and um
and then i started my organization and
so now this is like a huge part of my
life
well yeah and jasmine first of all it's
good to know that batman isn't
islamophobic so that's all
that's away of all of our shoulders but
also as well isn't part of the problem
we talk about islam
but like all religions like christianity
and judaism there's various different
sects
some are more conservative than others
so to talk about
the religion itself it doesn't really
get to the heart of the issues with
certain sects of the of the religion
well um i guess i should clarify
that you know islam is very different
from christianity so in christianity you
have like 30
000 different sects or something like
that in islam
90 of muslims are
sunni muslim so that's how i grew up
so when we talk about the the religion
of islam
we're talking about that
you know basically the words on the page
because unlike the bible the quran is
the literal word of allah
so it's not metaphorical these are not
stories
this these are edicts right it's it's a
it's a law book
these are rules and so
i guess there it's important not to
conflate islam
and muslims islam is the religion the
words on the page
um you know the the the the scripture
the um the demands that the religion
makes
okay so those are very clear scholars
have been
you know studying those for years they
make sharia laws based on them
and like i said 90 of muslims follow
sunni islam the other 10 are mostly
so think of saudi arabia 90 of muslims
follow that
and about 10 percent of muslims follow
iran's
islam now if you look at saudi arabia
and you look at iran you'll notice
there's really not that much difference
between the two countries as far as
sharia it's
you know it's the same stuff they'll
they'll both kill homosexuals
they'll both kill people for leaving
islam um
they both force women into modesty
clothing
iran a bit more because they'll actually
imprison women
saudi arabia doesn't imprison women
anymore
but a lot of women have been imprisoned
and still are in prison
and a lot of women were being imprisoned
in saudi arabia for wanting to drive but
no women in
in iran were ever imprisoned for wanting
to drive
so even though it's a little bit of a
different flavor
in how they are misogynist sexist evil
towards women
it's you know very similar um so that is
the the religion of islam it's sharia
basically it's it's quran it's hadith
it's sira the life of the prophet
then there are close to 2 billion
muslims
so i think that's what you're talking
about there so there's
the the way people follow their religion
of course
varies wildly right you could have
somebody
all the way on the left like majid nawaz
for example
who is a reformed muslim and so
you know he believes in the quality of
the sexes
he is not an anti-semite he believes in
um in lgbt equality et cetera et cetera
things that would cause him to be
killed by people on the opposite side of
the spectrum
even though they also both of them both
extremes call themselves
muslim and then of course you've got all
the muslims in between
so it's every anywhere from imagine
nawaz to like isis
on the other end and um
everybody is calling themselves muslim
but they are
all following the religion differently
in that some are going to
follow it word for word and not ignore
one single letter
which would be isis and then other
muslims who choose to cherry pick and
say well no
i'm not actually gonna do that because
i don't think we should you know
stone people to death for adultery or i
don't think that we should
uh cut off the hands of thieves or
whatever the case may be
jasmine sorry to interrupt may i just
jump in there because i think that's a
really important point that you made
there so
quite often uh certainly in this country
in britain we're told when there's a
terrorist attack
or when this issue is being discussed
that isis or al qaeda or any other
islamic inspired terrorist organization
these are people who
quote unquote have perverted the faith
of islam
whereas what you've just said and
correct me if i'm wrong because i'm just
trying to understand
what you've just said is actually the
opposite in other words
the people who are not committing these
attacks or who are not engaging in
throwing gays off buildings or whatever
those are the people who are not
following
the religion where's the people that's
correct so what you're saying
essentially is
isis have a literal interpretation of
the 100 yeah
who are not doing any of that they are
the ones who are not following the faith
of islam
to the left correct yes correct so it's
like if you think of it if i'm going to
compare that to christianity
if you think of people who follow the
old testament so think of westboro
baptist church or something
they are going to be very literal and
follow
exactly what that book says um
whereas most christians would have no
problem eating shellfish or whatever
the other rules are you know like so
it's kind of like that
so yes the the muslim the isis um
al-qaeda all of the jihadis over there
they are
following the religion to the letter
and this is why it's really
um that that's not it's not a true
statement to say that they're the ones
that are
perverting the religion or they're
hijacking the religion
um the the truth is that and i mean the
word perverting and hijacking don't work
because i think it's a positive thing
that people are cherry-picking and
choosing not to follow aspects of the
religion
so um i completely support muslims who
want
to you know maintain their identities as
muslims but also want to
live in this century and to live as
progressive liberal people and who don't
want to
follow very conservative right-wing
ideology that is
uh you know barbaric and archaic
yes man why do you think it is that in a
world which is more technical
technologically advanced than it's ever
been
uh particularly in the in the west in
liberal democracies and so on and so
forth that we have suddenly seen a rise
in this type of very very conservative
outlook
amongst young people in particular well
i think it's
unfortunate that those are the voices
that you hear
because those are the voices that are
not scared to speak up
the truth is there is a tsunami
of people that are leaving islam i mean
i don't think anyone's left
in islam and iran i mean that's
obviously hyperbole
but most iranians are because they have
sharia because they have the islamic
regime
because they're getting pure
unsugar-coated
islam they hate it
and the same thing happened in iraq as
well
when isis you know was big
in iraq people were leaving islam in
droves
because they were seeing oh my gosh is
this what my religion teaches because
it's very different when it's
theoretical
and when you actually see it and that's
exactly what happened to me
with 9 11. when 9 11 happened
it wasn't i wasn't it's kind of hard to
explain it's like you knew that that's
what you're supposed to do
you understand that they were following
the religion and that was the right
thing
but you feel so sick just as a human
being
so you're kind of conflicted
and it pushes you to deal with that
with that conflict in your mind right
with that with that cognitive dissonance
and just like me
that hundreds of thousands if not
millions of people are started leaving
the religion when they started to see
what isis were doing in iraq and syria
so i think that it's unfortunate
that you don't get to hear their voices
and you don't get to see their faces and
you
there are a lot of feminists all
over saudi arabia all over iran all over
egypt all over the muslim world
that can't speak because if they do
i mean you they know what jihadis do
right they they they live in that world
like
we know there's so many cases i could
tell you there's people that have been
hacked to death in the streets of
bangladesh
people that have been beaten to death in
in pakistan
people being stabbed i mean this is
happening now in europe but this is not
new news for anybody
in the muslim majority world i mean as
we're talking now
35 kids at a university in afghanistan
just died yesterday
sunnis killing shias muslims killing
muslims
and so we're used to that kind of
violence
at every turn and that's why people are
too scared to speak up
so there are a lot of other magic
nawazes out there
but they're not living in the uk so they
can't put their faces and their names
out there
they can have private twitter accounts
and interact with me and interact with
each other
but you don't get to see them you don't
get to hear from them
i mean recently there was a bunch of
mosques in france that all
signed this paper that basically said
we denounce people that say muslims are
being discriminated against in france
that's a lie that's not true we're happy
here we love it here
not one single person signed their name
to that
they sign the names of the mosques that
they belong to
and the organizations that they belong
to because they
know that if they sign their name to
that paper
they're putting their life and their
family's life at risk
so it's incredibly dangerous for
moderate
muslims to speak out and so it just
looks like the conservatives
are um the majority or
it looks like they're the ones that are
that everybody else is okay with it
because nobody's pushing back i hear
that a lot people are like why aren't
why aren't muslims pushing back against
this and
and i equate it kind of to the woke
culture
because it's a way of getting them to to
relate it to something in their lives
that they can understand
and i say well you know in america or
britain or anywhere in europe
people are afraid to speak up against
woke culture
because they're afraid it might affect
their job or they're afraid people might
call them racist they're afraid
that friends or family might judge them
or treat them differently or even stop
being friends with them
so multiply that by like a few thousand
and that's the kind of fear muslims feel
about speaking up against the extremists
in their religion
because not only will they lose their
jobs they will lose their jobs they'll
lose their livelihoods they'll lose
their family and they could lose their
heads as well
right do you enjoy watching problematic
content online
that you don't want your friends or
family to know about of course they do
they watch trigonometry mate
well we have just the solution for you
it's called express
vpn at the moment your isp is able to
track
every single website that you go to and
then they sell that information onto
advertisers and others
expressvpn allows you to prevent that
from happening
it also means that you can be located in
a different region to the one that your
ip shows up as
we always use expressvpn for our
browsing don't be francis
absolutely and by the way you sound like
an expert
keep your browsing history to yourself
visit expressvpn.com
forward slash trigger today to get three
months free subscription
visit expressvpn.com
trigger that's e x p r e s s
vpn dot com slash trigger
today good job spelling out for the men
doesn't sound patronizing at all
absolutely and by the way all those
little words you use i've got no idea
what they mean
yasmine let me push back very gently on
some of that because when francis was
asking you about
why we're seeing a lot of muslims in the
west
remain very conservative down the
generations
we have surveys in this country and if
you if you poll muslims in britain about
homosexuality about sex outside of
marriage about
what should happen to apostates you do
find that there's a very significant
majority of people and actually
quite often the younger generation uh
have a more strict code that they follow
or at least
think of so why is that happening which
i guess
was the point of france's question yeah
i mean
believe it or not those polls
as abysmal as they are are way better
than if you polled people
in the muslim majority world so people
that do
come to the west their minds are
getting opened it very it's it's a slow
process and the thing is is it's
it's it's not just risky as far as
like if you're in pakistan you could go
to prison or you could be killed
or you could be lashed in the streets in
saudi arabia the all of these things are
true
but even if you're in europe or in north
america
you're going to be judged by your
community you're going to be judged by
your family and
so you're too scared to even have those
thoughts in your own head
this is i'll give you my my experience
growing up i knew i was supposed to hate
non-muslims
i knew i was supposed to hate jewish
people i knew i was supposed to hate gay
people
how did you know that so because i was
taught that i was
that was that that's the rules right
like this is
you you you must hate anything that
allah hates this is a very common
thing right so if allah hates gay people
then you must hate gay people allah
loves prophet muhammad you must love
prophet muhammad you have to
you know there's they call it the
mustachim the long thin it's also almost
like a tightrope when they when they put
it visually
it's a tightrope and on below the
tightrope
is hell so you have to walk a very
very thin straight line and do not waver
or you will fall
into the depths of hell so there's no
thinking involved you just constantly
have to stay focused
so you don't you don't you're not
allowed to question
things it's really hard to to to i'm
gonna try and convey to you guys what it
feels like to be indoctrinated like
as a child to have the fear of hell
put in you they tell you in detail
about how your skin will and your your
flesh will melt off
and then it will regrow and then it will
melt off again
and i remember asking my mom at like six
years old like well if that keeps on
happening won't you eventually get used
to it and she's like no
each time it's going to hurt just like
the first time you know
and you get told of ada that means like
all of
the uh
punishments that are going to happen to
you when you're in the grave waiting for
the day of judgment
so the snakes that are going to go into
your eyeballs and blah blah blah blah so
really really really vicious
scary stuff that you're told as a little
kid
and by the time you're an adult
and you want to start questioning it's
like
you know there's i think you even have a
saying and chris janet is something like
give me a child
younger than seven and and then i'll
give you the man or something like that
like once you've indoctrinated them
is yeah it's a jesuit saying give me the
boy at eight years old and i'll show you
the man at 18.
yeah yeah so it's kind of like that they
just indoctrinate you from a young age
and then by the time you're an adult
it's like
too difficult for you to even go there
because you've been
your mind has been so trained to stay
on this long thin straight line and not
to waver
and so even though i knew that i was
supposed to that i had to
hate gay people hate jewish people want
non-muslims to be killed
want islam to spread across the world
want the caliphate to rise
pledge my allegiance that when the
caliphate rises that i would go and
support it
you know all of this stuff and you you
you spew all the stuff you're supposed
to spew but
you never really think about it
you just you're just kind of like well
you're brainwashed right so you're just
you're just repeating it and
so if i were to sign or if i were to
fill out one of those polls at that time
i would be horrified by my results i was
one of those women that would say i want
to wear hijab
i like it right it protects me it keeps
me modest
right you just you say what you need to
say
and you do what you need to do because
you're so scared of
burning in hell and yes man you're so
scared of losing your family and you're
so scared of all of the horrible things
that could happen
and yes i mean but on these values
completely at odds with living in a
secular western society they 100
are and i think that that's what the
problem is
now i think the problem is that well
there's two problems number one people
are not willing to admit
that these values are not only the
opposite of western values but they
are against western value they oppose
western values
that's the first thing people need to
accept that and understand that
and deal with that and secondly
which is really unfortunate is that now
there is no pride
in western values there's no push back
so at least when i was growing up i
would hear in the
home you need to wear hijab so that you
don't get raped because if you get raped
it's your fault because you didn't cover
yourself properly i'm hearing victim
blaming i'm hearing [ __ ] shaming
i'm hearing like textbook rape culture
at home but when i left the house
i would hear the exact opposite i would
hear very very
feminist strong you know
messages that oppose the messages i was
hearing
in the house and so that allowed me
to it allowed it to push through the
indoctrination
what's happening today unfortunately
is that kids who are like me being grown
growing up in these muslim households
that are being told these things like
democracy is terrible um you know
feminism is a is a lie liberalism is
is is a failure all of these things
those things unfortunately is being
supported outside the home
too right when when the charlie hebdo
when people were being killed over
cartoons the reaction
should have been immediate printing of
those cartoons
on every single western media possible
as a show of strength to say no we
believe in freedom of expression we
believe in freedom of speech
we will not be bullied we will not
capitulate
but instead we capitulated and we said
well we shouldn't hurt their feelings
and da da da da
and while we're busy capitulating
they're busy feeling
strong they're busy feeling the moral
certitude that you feel when allah is
behind you that's why you're winning
right that's that's why we're a lit
we're able to make these europeans
get down on their knees is because we
are in the right and they are in the
wrong and we are stronger than they are
and we are smarter than they are and we
have allah behind us and they don't and
we are muslims and they are non-muslims
etc etc so that's
that us versus them mentality
is being unfortunately um
uh what's the word i'm looking for guys
well it's been spread
through through the whole of society
yeah no i
i think it's being spread and it's being
validated like everything that they're
being taught
is being validated outside in the real
world
and that's terrifying to me
like this when i saw the the hebdo
cartoons
on this the buildings in france i
i honestly i teared up with joy i was
like this is what you need
to do that is exactly it
a show of strength that has zero
violence
but it's saying we will not
bend the knee that's exactly how you
need to respond because
they are very strong so we need to
respond
with strength as well yasmin and what do
you say to people who say well all that
would do is antagonize
people unnecessarily it would be
offensive to many muslims who otherwise
wouldn't be involved
you would obviously lead quite likely to
more reprisal attacks so
innocent people all over the west would
pay with their lives for this
uh unnecessary offense that we're giving
to muslims
it's it's not unnecessary the thing is
is
it's your values right especially for
french people
right equality fraternity
liberty these this this is this is their
country
so for them to bend the knee when it
comes to something like that
is so much more than just like people
would say things like
oh it's just cartoons just stop printing
them and everything will be okay
that is so not true look at indonesia
look at
egypt look at maldives look at
so many different countries it doesn't
work that way
you how do can you imagine ever somebody
saying to their kid comes home and says
there's a bully
that's beating me up and he's saying he
wants to take my lunch money every day
and you as the parent would say well
just give him your money give him your
money and then he'll stop
right like no he won't he's gonna keep
going he's going to feel empowered
and he's going to feel strong and he's
going to feel you know he's going to
he's going to do more and he can get
more out of you
and that is exactly what happens history
has shown that over and over again for
the past 40 years
ever since the islamic regime in iran
people have been scared shitless all
over the muslim world
because they're like oh the extremists
are going to get us oh no the jihadis in
their
in their suicide vests are going to get
us so we have to give them what they
want we have to give them what they want
and they are constantly giving up all of
their freedoms
all of their secularism you know women
are giving up their their freedoms as
well
almost happily because they're trading
it
for what this false sense of security
think of the the black box
in the plane when the hijackers
were about to fly their planes
into the world trade center what did
they say
they said just sit down and be quiet and
we'll fly back to the airport
everything's going to be okay nobody do
anything stupid
just sit down and be quiet everything's
gonna be fine
that's that's just what they said
before they killed everybody on board
so appeasing bullies appeasing
terrorists is never ever
ever the right direction to go and you
think it's cartoons today it's not going
to stop
here as long as soon as you give up one
of your main freedoms
or anything they're just going to keep
pushing for more and more more and more
more and more
until the whole world is exactly how
they want it to be
bowing to allah and yes min
there is a counter argument to that
which is obviously you know saying that
you know
islam is is one of the i think it's a
protected characteristic in the uk
that we talk about how you know
islamophobia
um is similar to anti-semitism do you
agree with that
or do you agree with the term okay
not at all because anti there it
when you're jewish that is your ethnic
tribe
as well as your religion in fact a lot
of jewish people
it's only their ethnic tribe and they're
atheists they're not
right is that yeah exactly so
when you say it's a protective class
that's that makes sense that's like
saying yeah a jewish person can be
protected class
black person gay person etc etc
but are christians a protective class
right it's it's it's muslims are just
it's just a religion it's not an
ethnicity
and so there is this hope that they can
conflate it with
anti-semitism that they can say oh look
it's the same thing islamophobia
anti-semitism it's not the same thing
it's very different islamophobia is not
anti-muslim bigotry they're not worried
about
the human beings they're worried about
the religion that's why it's called
islamophobia
because they don't want you to criticize
their religion
which is exactly what all of this
charlie hebdo nonsense is about
it's because from their perspective
they're not allowed to draw muhammad
so if they're not allowed to draw
muhammad you're not allowed to draw
muhammad
that's the rule and that's that they
don't
you know if you are drawing muhammad
that is an insult to their religion
and so they want to stop
you from insulting their religion or
criticizing their religion or doing
something that is against their religion
and so that's why all of these terrorist
attacks have been happening
and why do we have these uh i guess you
i think it'd be accurate to describe
them as double standards you mentioned
christianity it's perfectly
normal to mock christianity whole slaves
of culture have been devoted to it
comedically artistically and otherwise
uh
obviously that that treatment doesn't
seem to be the same in this case why do
you think that is
i think it's because people don't
understand that
muslims are not a race muslims are not
in ethnicity
they're not they haven't clued in that
it's more similar to christianity in
that sense than it is to judaism
they don't you know i try to make the
argument like you know
you know a catholic person from italy or
from mexico or from america or from
britain
they have in very different cultures
very different religions very different
music
art everything they don't share anything
except for a lot of religion yes
that's right and muslims are like that
too
you know you've got muslims these the
the teenager that killed samuel petty
was from chechnya
same thing the the two brothers that did
the boston bombing
so they're from russia you've got people
from albania you've got people from
germany you've got people from america
you've got people from egypt
saudi arabia these are places people
that are wildly different they are not
an ethnic group
they are they are not a tribe they are
they share nothing in common culturally
except for the
i mean they don't share anything
culturally what they share is the
religion
of islam and i think that in the west
there you know people can't even tell
the difference between a pakistani and
an arab
for the longest time people were saying
imagine nawaz was arab i'm like
what what part of arabia is pakistan
like there's just not um unfortunately
even though it's the second largest
religion on the planet it's such a
minority group
in the west that people are just not
aware of it they don't understand
um i mean they are do you really think
that's true asthma do you not think it's
just people are afraid
people are afraid of the repercussions
of criticizing islam so we've invented
the word islamophobia
to shut people up because if people
aren't shut up then they're going to say
and do things that offend muslims
which will result in reprisals well yeah
so the word islamophobia was created by
the muslim brotherhood
who are islamists similar to hezbollah
so what's important to know about
islamists is that they have the exact
same goal as the jihadis so islam
requires that the whole world be muslim
that
everybody bow to allah that's the the
that's what the religion
demands that muslims do so there's
different ways of doing it
you've got the jihadis on one end so
that's all of these terrorists al-qaeda
you know isis boko haram et cetera et
cetera or all of the lone wolves
all over the world they want to
terrorize people so that they
bow to islam basically they never
criticize the religion
that they just um
that that they are in control and then
you have the islamists who are like
muslim brotherhood
hezbollah you know the organization of
islamic cooperatives so
turkey um you know erdogan
they are people in nice suits that speak
you know with
with they don't they don't look like
jihadis right they look like proper
diplomats
but they have the exact same goal but
they're not going to do it in the
same way jihadis will do it through
murdering people
islamists will do it through
more diplomatic means so they outline
the three ways that they're going to do
it
one of them is through immigration
another way is and through immigration
by that i mean so by the time muslims
reach a certain point of uh population
then they can make demands because
they're a voting bloc now
so that's then so immigration is
important for that reason and
also through the wombs of the muslim
mothers so each man marry four wives
continue to have babies to grow the umma
so that you can have
more control and then thirdly through
using secular laws
against themselves so basically using
those secular laws
to to so that they can bring islam in
you know
yeah so so so when you say that the word
islamophobia is to stop criticism of the
religion you are a hundred percent
correct that is exactly why it was
created
in the same way that cutting off a
teacher's head is a way to stop
criticism of the of the religion it's
just two different methods
towards the same goal and
you brought up that awful awful case
which happened in france a matter of
weeks ago
nobody seems to be talking about it
anymore nobody seems to be discussing it
there doesn't seem to be any particular
outrage it just seems that you know all
the
particularly the white liberals have
shrugged their shoulders and we've all
moved on
why is that
you know it's it's
you know like i said earlier it's
terrifying for me to see that
it was so scary for me to see
how nobody really cared about
the issue with samuel petit except for
people in france i mean you didn't hear
any voices coming out of the uk or out
of the u.s
in fact the u.s was writing headlines
that made it seem like the
french police were the bad guys in this
scenario because they killed the guy
who just behead a teacher um
so the reason why it terrifies me is
because
it's to your own detriment like the fact
that you're not paying attention to
these things
first of all it feels like a betrayal
too like you know like with with george
floyd
the whole world started having
um you know walkouts all over the world
protests
in support of george floyd but where
where were the protests in support of
samuel pt
anywhere in the world it's like nobody
why why why didn't his life matter
you know he's a teacher doing his job
talking about freedom of expression like
that's
that should have been
that should have shook everybody to
their core and made everybody say
hold on a minute that's an attack on
our basic freedoms but
um you know unfortunately that didn't
happen
and then there were very closely after
it there were a few other terrorist
attacks in france and now one in vienna
and so there's just constant terror
happening and it takes people's
attention away and to be honest it
reminds me
of like living in the middle east where
you become desensitized to these things
it's like oh there is another suicide
bombing of the market
oh how many people died 11 oh only 11
that's good
so did you want some more rice like you
just it's it's part of life now
right and and now it's becoming a part
of life for europeans too
and they they don't even seem to be
bothered by it well i think a lot of
people are bothered by
yasmin but i think the question that i
was going to ask you ties in very neatly
into that which is
do you think that you know the answer to
france's question why
why aren't people still talking about is
so really
we don't feel like we can do anything
about it because
i i don't know what you know if there
was a policy
that you said you said to me constantine
what you need to do
is advocate for this policy for the
government to follow and then all of
this will be fixed
i think a lot of people would sign up to
that if it was a sensible
thing to do but i don't know what that
looks like
well so two things first of all the
jihadis they were told
to do terrorism now while the
governments are busy with covid
so they knew that this was going to be a
good time
because everybody's so busy with the
pandemic right
and so everybody you're fighting for
like when you talk about what can people
do i think a lot of people are starting
when i say people i don't mean when i'm
lamenting that nobody seems to care
about it i'm not talking about
individual people i'm not talking about
you or me
i'm talking about governments right
right
um i'm talking about
what what exactly like what you just
said to have some
actual policies but that requires them
to sit down
and to figure that out and i think that
ever
they're they're just drowning right now
well in america i know they're drowning
with their
um with the election going on
france is in lockdown you know uk is in
lockdown
everybody's so busy with other things
that they really haven't
they're not able to sit down and say
what are we going to do
about this problem well we've had 19
years since 9 11 which sort of started
this process in a major way
i don't think we've come up with a
solution i mean is there a solution to
this thing that's
that makes sense that you may because
one of the things we have to deal with
is
in western societies we do have
significant muslim minorities
as you say there are some islamists who
are trying to use that
against the societies in which that's
happening but how do you deal with that
you know if you'd have asked me this
before the huge influx of refugees
uh i would have had a lot more hope i
would have given you a different answer
because
but nobody listened to us back then
either but
but you know we're at a situation now
where
it's it's pretty bad but
we need to act before it gets worse and
now when i say act
what i personally think we should be
doing
is understanding and it's it's
almost it's really difficult for people
who are born and raised in the west and
who don't have any experience or
understanding with islam but
if you rely on people who are secular
muslims
who are reformed muslims who are
ex-muslims
people that understand those societies
people that understand those mindsets
lean on them and
let them give you
advice and the advice that they will
give you
is that you need to be able to
distinguish
between a muslim and an islamist
which is you know sometimes
very easy but sometimes not so easy so
like the pulse nightclub shooting
in um in florida that was done by an
afghani man his wife didn't wear hijab
he was born and raised in america
he's not so easy to be able to tell
right away
this is there's going to be trouble
there
this latest terrorist attack in vienna
same thing he was imprisoned for a while
and he was let go for good behavior
and they're shocked that he did this
because they never thought that
he would be capable they thought that he
was reformed
and that he was you know cured of his
need to go to syria and you know
support the caliphate so
it's definitely not going to be a
hundred percent
but sometimes it's pretty [ __ ]
obvious
and it's very very infuriating like when
you open the doors to your country and
you're just like come on
in and people were not only coming from
syria they were coming from morocco from
tunisia from iran from
they're coming from everywhere because
the doors were wide open
you know 15 year olds or
sorry like older men i don't know with
beers are pretending that they're minors
and they're like oh yeah i'm 15 years
old so that they could
get you know more social security
support whatever
um there was a whole bunch of
this isn't even new what i'm saying like
if you read ion hersey ali's book
which she wrote probably 15 years ago by
now
she talked about this happening with the
somali community going into holland
when they were going into there and they
would they would just lie
and say whatever needed to be said so
that they could get
the social support that they needed and
if anybody tried to call them on their
lies they'd say are you being racist
and then that would everybody would be
like no no no no
no i'm not being racist it's okay please
continue to steal from us but just don't
call me a racist
and you know imagine nawaz talks about
that in his book radical
same thing he talked about how
he was in his university he was
radicalizing students
publicly and when his administration
tried to call him out on it
he accused them of being islamophobic
and racist and bigots and so they shut
up
and they let him continue um
radicalizing students until
a student was stabbed in the middle of
the
courtyard in the university and then
they finally shut down the
radicalization
so using anyway
i started i started going off in a whole
bunch of tangents but basically what you
need to do
is you need to be careful that the
people that you're inviting into your
country
are people that share the same values
as you do or at least if not exactly the
same
similar values so let's take the syrian
conflict for
example in syria when that happened
people had the option of helping yazidi
people
who were people who were being killed
women and children
that were being raped no organizations
were helping yezidis
organizations were instead helping sunni
muslims
which is the people that were supporting
isis
and so when you see when i see a sunni
muslim
covering her face seven children
chances of that family um
one of those seven kids growing up and
being radicalized
are you know pretty high
so you gotta make the decisions not
based on what looks good
you know because for us in canada it was
about our prime minister wanted to take
pictures with women in hijab because it
looks
looks like he's all diverse and
inclusive and makes them look so
progressive
they have the same skin color he says
him most of the time yeah
um yeah that's true
but they weren't making decisions based
on
who are the gay syrians that are in
danger of being killed
who are the ex-muslim syrians who are in
danger of being killed
right who are the yazidi syrians who are
in danger of being killed
like triage it differently triage it
based on
not only who is in most danger but
who will be able to integrate into your
society easier because they're going to
um
already share similar values as you do
but if you're going to choose people
whose values are like
way to the right of you then don't be
surprised if they have trouble
integrating and yes
i mean the question is is do you think
that
those types of people then that over
time they will be able to adapt
to a western culture or do you think
that they will
always remain on the outside as a result
of their values and their beliefs
i'll ask you this if you moved to cuba
do you think over time you would start
to think that communism was
great my mother's from venezuela so i
think you've got the answer to that
question there so how about that so if
you moved to venezuela would you all of
a sudden be like yay socialism
uh well i do need to lose weight so um
maybe for a month or so yeah but you
know people
don't their their beliefs don't change
if because they have moved to a
different geographic location
they are the same people and they're
going to teach those values to their
children as well
and in their schools if they're if they
have private schools
and in their mosques or in their
churches or in their whatevers
um so i don't think it's organically
just gonna change
sorry to jump in is this about a failure
of integration
is this about no and thank you for
asking that because that's something
that i
always like to mention because i need to
you know there's so much white guilt
going on all the time and i'm like
just just relax because and and this
you know i just watched a documentary uh
was it itv
i don't know it was british where um
somebody was going into mosques and she
had like us
a camera and she was recording with what
they were saying in the mosques and
stuff like that she's a muslim woman
now in those recordings
there was something that happened they
showed a part of what happened but then
they didn't really talk about it which i
think it was important to talk about
what was important to talk about was how
the people in the mosques were teaching
the uh parishioners
that they are not allowed to befriend
non-muslims you can live in their
country
use their you know because you have they
have better systems in place right
better education better social welfare
better xyz much you know for a million
things that are better than like you
know
mogadishu or whatever so come live in
their countries
but you need to hate what allah hates
and allah hates non-muslims so you're
not
supposed to befriend them or just smile
at them on the streets
they are your enemy don't forget that so
one of the sayings which is common and i
also heard it in another documentary
um that somebody said it which is if
you're born
in a barn that doesn't make you a horse
and that's something that they tell kids
all the time
just because you're born in britain it
doesn't make you british
just because you're born in canada it
doesn't make you canadian you are
muslim this is your ummah this is your
allegiance is your loyalty is to muslims
and your non-muslims are your enemy
so i hear this constant thing about like
uh people in the west thinking that it's
their fault
that muslims were that our muslims are
having trouble with integration it's
like no this is a two-way street they
don't want to
integrate with you they're now this is
of course i'm making a generalization
this isn't true for
all muslims but the ones that i'm
talking of the group that i'm talking
about
it is true for them there are muslims
who do not actively do not want to
integrate with non-muslims
they don't want to even learn your
language
when they're living in your country so
you know you have to remember that it's
it's a two-way street so yes you know
it's it's important to
make it as easy as possible for people
to immigrate
or not to immigrate but to integrate
into your countries by offering
free language courses or free culture
courses or whatever the case may be i
don't know i know that sweden and other
countries are doing stuff like that
but also keep in mind that there are
some people that aren't going to
want what you are offering and
if integration fails to happen it's not
necessarily because you didn't
offer the right environment for that
but it's because some people
just don't want to and that was my
family that was exactly my experience
that's why i went to islamic schools and
that's why i wasn't allowed to interact
with non-muslim people yeah because
i was going to just say we're running
out of time quickly and every interview
we do now
there's no no no it's an absolute
pleasure speaking with you but every
interview
we do now we have to end with a sort of
self-deprecating joke about how positive
and upbeat
it's been this has been no exception
at all um yeah i think i think we've
asked a lot more questions than we've
answered today uh but i do think they're
at least important to ask
uh so with that uh we've got one more
question for you which is always what's
the one thing that we're not talking
about
but we really should be well
if i if i can be you know take this
moment
to actually bring up my organization
free hearts free minds
which is an organization that i created
to support
people who have left islam but are
living in muslim majority countries
and so if you're interested to know what
we do and how we help people please go
to our website
freeheartsfreeminds.com and click on
testimonials and then you can read
stories
from people who have been through our
program
and they tell you how how we've helped
them
and your book is unveiled and where can
people follow you online
uh they can follow me on yasmin muhammad
on twitter or
on facebook and instagram as well
that's great thank you so much yasmin uh
thank you so much for watching guys
if you've enjoyed this interview and
you're new to the show
our episodes go out on wednesday and
sunday always at 7 pm uk time and our
live stream
constantin they are also at 7pm on
tuesday
thursday friday and saturday every
single week we will see you
very soon with another episode or live
stream take care and see you soon guys
thanks for watching guys as always
subscribe to the youtube channel
click the bell button next to subscribe
button so you get notified when a video
comes out
and follow us on all the social media at
trigger pod
and also leave us a nice review on
itunes and spread the word